I don't like that lunch can overextend
itself you ever go into a restaurant and
it's 4 30 and they're like I just want
to get some lunch you're like no no
dinner starts at five we stopped lunch
what's your arrogant ass dinner budding
its noses no it's not dinner's got to be
the star of the show on dinner no we
gotta be the only thing is there a break
between breakfast and lunch yes you go
to get yeah you go to get lunch and they
go no lunch starts in two hours because
we're in the in between breakfast and
lunch it only happens oh it's actually
lunch and dinner they start breakfast
service for lunch though for sure but
then lunch comes out with lunch if you
guys Show hours and they stop lunch
there's no food dinner starts at five
and they they just stop after lunch
lunch can't see you through to dinner I
have not seen in a long time a
restaurant last week